For this quiz, I just want to make sure that you understand
the definition of the clustering coefficient.
So I'd like you to compute the clustering coefficient for a node in this graph.
Now, this graph is inspired by the flight graph for a major imaginary airline in the United States.
And it has flights that go between Seattle, Los Angeles, Dallas, Chicago, Pittsburgh, Atlanta,
Raleigh-Durham, Philadelphia, and Providence.
This is just kind of a random selection of big cities in the US, but with emphasis on places I've lived.
As usual, I've drawn edges between cities. In this case, if there is a flight between them.
And what we'd like you to compute for this example
is the clustering coefficient for Chicago with the airport code ORD.
So compute that quantity and write it in the box.